so thanks for the introduction I call
all kind of elaborate a little more on
on what Tina said about my background as
we get going here the first thing I want
to do is give a very very brief
background and information this is us ok
this is driver some of you may have read
this article last year when you were
following Stanford football but first
before we talk about anything related to
the business that I'm running right now
I want to talk about virtual reality at
large and just kind of educate you guys
really quickly so who has heard a
virtual reality you are living under a
rock if you have not in the Bay Area
okay good so the first thing there's
virtual reality and there's augmented
reality k so for the purpose of this
conversation we're gonna talk about VR
but really quickly I just want to
educate you guys how many people have
been to the Stanford virtual human
interaction lab here on campus Jeremy
valence him okay not as many as I would
thought I would have thought so if you
haven't please go Jeremy is one of the
best in the world he is one of the main
reasons why mark zuckerberg bought
oculus for two billion dollars a couple
years ago I believe zuckerberg was in
his lab week or two before that purchase
and Jeremy basically helped convince
mark this stuff literally could take
over the world so he's a fascinating guy
he's really really good at what he does
his lab is phenomenal so please go check
that out if you haven't already so vr vs
a are the main differences are in
virtual reality you have in theory you
have complete immersion so when you have
a virtual reality headset on if it's
doing its job you should feel completely
present in another place so if I'm
standing in the room right now and I'm
in a virtual version of the room I
should literally be able to walk around
as if I'm right there if I'm in a
virtual madison square garden or a
virtual Egyptian pyramid landscape area
I should be able to walk exactly scale
for scale to where I am and I should
feel completely immersed bad rich
reality does not achieve this so there's
a lot of really really bad stuff out
there with this industry kind of kind of
taking fire but good VR allows you to
achieve complete presence in the
environment that you think that you're
supposed to be in our brains because the
stuff is so new as humans have not
caught up to the fact that we have a
headset on something in the back of your
brain still thinks that it's real so
when it's done right people completely
completely zone out those of you that
have been in the lab have you done the
pit raise your hand okay it's only a
couple so when you're standing in
Jeremy's lab and he has you stand right
here and he says take a step forward and
you do
and then he removes a hole in the room
and creates a pit in front of you people
literally start sweating in their heart
rate goes up now you're thinking right
now that's impossible it really can't be
that real right I'm standing in the room
I know that if I do this I'm just going
to do that in the real world what is it
two out of three one out of three adult
males will not step off the plank into
the virtual pit literally all they have
to do is this okay and then the virtual
world when they do that they're going to
drop and they're going to make you feel
like you drop you're gonna feel like you
hit the floor people freak out some some
very prominent NFL players that you guys
watch on Sundays have been in Jeremy's
lab they would not step off the plank
and all it required was this these guys
are you know 64 250 pounds and they were
like you know low kids so it's very very
real augmented reality is when we're
taking some sort of heads up display
whether it be glasses whether it be a
helmet and we're showing some sort of
stimuli on the screen so one of the
really really cool use cases for
augmented reality and in several years
it's not complete immersion maybe I'm
walking through a factory floor and as
I'm walking down the hall I have stimuli
popping up saying that's too hot don't
touch that you know this is a button
that does this this does this so you're
going through some type of you know
training safety training where you're
having stimuli introduced while you
still feel like you're in the real the
real world are we all on the same page
makes sense okay so there's a couple key
terms that I want you guys understand as
it pertains to be are so the first is
tracking so imagine you're playing
pacman okay you're holding the remote
control you push the remote control
forward the computer is tracking which
way you push the remote control and
that's how it's being told what to do so
in pac-man if i push this way right
pac-man is going to move that way the
second is rendering so once i move the
controller the computer has to rerender
the seen so many thousands of times per
millisecond so there's no lag to really
trick your brain like you're there and
it rear enders it for where you're going
to go next so impact man I move the
thing forward he eats one little ball
right move it left he eats a ball this
way the computer is rendering that scene
really really fast so hopefully when
you're in a virtual environment your
brain is tricked into thinking you're
there and then last one is display if
all of these things are not done
correctly okay and display is obviously
displaying the information of the user
if these things are not done correctly
particularly the last two it won't work
so for display
if I walk closer to Tina and she doesn't
look bigger to me in the real world or
the virtual world right because that's
what happens in the real world it's just
you're going to tune out it's not going
to work so when this is not done
properly a it makes people really
nauseous people have bad experiences and
then they're done they don't want to
look at vr ever again be from a
cognitive standpoint it just really
doesn't doesn't work so we'll talk about
why that's important as it relates to
Stryver here in a few minutes okay last
couple things here one of the really
cool things that we have done at striver
is we have solved a real world problem
football players never have enough
practice time on the field athletes in
general never have enough practice time
they always could get more mental reps
at the highest level are very very
important so can a virtual simulation
give you more work right so we've taken
a real world problem and we would use
technology to solve that problem we
think so this but this is really
important virtual reality is really not
that new but based on where the hardware
is today based on how good it is based
on how cheap it is relative to where it
was years ago you know in Jeremy's lab
probably eight years ago the helmet that
they're using that today costs 500 bucks
cost fifty thousand dollars so that's
how fast we've come from a hardware
standpoint and a computer computing
processing standpoint but historically
these have been the areas where VR has
been used so in medicine can I be a
doctor can I get virtual surgery right
can't get more reps as far as getting my
surgical technique in phobias can I can
i cure your fear of public speaking by
putting you in front of a virtual room
with a lot of people like you guys are
right now staring at me maybe my heart
rate goes up in the virtual world that
makes me more calm when I'm in the real
world we're doing this stuff in the lab
it does work and then lastly the
military has been using VR for years a
grant of the graphics haven't been very
good but imagine I'm going through a
virtual Iraq I'm getting the experience
of what it's like to clear a room and
getting the experience of what it's like
to interact with somebody of a different
race culture gender and I'm going
through those simulations over and over
so when I'm in the real world hopefully
I perform you know to the best of my
ability based on my training so this
stuff has been happening okay one of the
things that really frustrates me about
the industry right now given that I'm
doing it every day I'm kind of the anti
VR VR CEO I don't think virtual reality
had
they're going to take over the world I
think it would be really really sad if
your generation would rather put
something on their face in the
anti-social in the real world versus you
know actually talk to somebody it's bad
enough doing this all the time now we're
going to put headset so we're going to
completely lose our sense of who we are
right so I don't think that's going to
happen I hope to god it doesn't i look
for real real world use cases to wear vr
and AR can actually be used and be
effective there are a lot of them there
are also a lot of ideas that are really
really bad okay now I'm not saying these
are bad ideas but the reason why we have
to be a little critical of this industry
and at least have some cautious optimism
as to where it can go is because when we
watch a movie for example the director
tells us where to look right they move
the camera they make a sound we always
know where to look based on what the
director is telling us that's been a
filmmaking principle for a hundred years
in VR if it's a 360-degree scene and I'm
looking over here but the director wants
me to look over there he just he or she
just lost right so how can you make a
movie a really really good virtual
experience as opposed to the traditional
2d model not saying that it's not
possible it's just a long way away from
people actually figuring it out video
games so gaming is going to be the thing
that drives VR at least in the interim
in the short term one of the things that
people are really under estimating both
with movies and video games is trust me
that headset is going to get very
uncomfortable after about 15 minutes so
gamers and some of you probably know
what I'm talking about in this room you
have this you play your games for hours
and hours at a time the gamers have told
the headset manufacturers we have no
interest in wearing the headset for four
hours and that's just a fact now some
will their eyes may be burning they may
get headaches who knows but it's a
really really different way to
experience gaming now it's cool don't
get me wrong it's really really cool I
just like to be cautiously optimistic
another thing to think about with games
is with the exception of like a
first-person shooter game if I'm trying
to play a sports game and I need to
literally run across the room in NVR
because that's what happens in the real
world that's probably not possible in my
living room right so when you think
about maybe playing madden in virtual
reality what's the one position that
really would be the only one that
applies probably the quarterback right
so you're going to stand there you're
going to fake throw it you're not going
to be a linebacker and go tackle your
mom in virtual reality it's just not
gonna happen so these are the things
that we have to be thinking about going
forward and you know the news and the
media it just wants to write VR VR VR VR
there's a lot of investment money going
into it probably rightfully so in a lot
of areas but I think we really need to
stop and think for a little bit about
what makes sense what doesn't what's
good what's bad and what people are
actually going to do in the long run ok
and then mobile and fan experience those
things make a lot of sense but again you
know one of the big pushes right now in
the sports world and we get calls all
the time hey we really want to stream
this live event in VR this game do you
guys do that and we say no we don't call
so and so and we're probably never going
to do it because we don't really believe
in it we believe in maybe the micro
bursts where I'm watching my big-screen
TV in the real world I throw on the
headset for two minutes to see what it's
like courtside but then I go back to the
to the real world experience the TV
talking to my friend talking to my wife
you know whatever so this is just
something that we have to actually
consider going forward as to how will
this stuff actually be used and it'll be
really interesting to see how it plays
out so that said what is Stryver we are
going to just snack you guys in the face
with it and Kevin Hogan it's like he's
playing a video game out there Sam and
in fact maybe that's because he has been
no doubt Reese I want you to picture
this with me about sitting in your tiny
office with another guy and you're doing
the usual thing working on cut-ups
envisioning the long road ahead as an
assistant coach when you come up with an
idea it's a pretty good idea and pretty
soon your head coach is telling you
you're gonna have to quit your job and
do this full time because your idea is
going to change the game welcome to
Stanford University where football meets
Silicon Valley the epicenter of
Technology here with the use of a
head-mounted display players and coaches
are immersed in a new virtual reality a
computer-generated simulation of a 3d
invite
when I first put those glasses on I
first saw what it looked like my mind
started racing which was okay this could
work and out but it work this could be
for naught they turn around and we tell
them to look behind him and they do this
and they say you know holy blank right
insert expletive here as a Stanford grad
assistant in 2014 driver co-founder and
CEO Derek belch introduced the software
to coaches and quarterbacks as an
alternative to film study and reps on
the practice field if you were at
Stanford practice you would see our 360
degree camera somewhere relatively close
to the player whose vantage point we
want and we would capture a certain
number of plays so start looking around
like all the way oh my god 350 360 you
don't know this right now but we are
looking at what you're looking at on the
screen oh cool so from a coaching
standpoint look right now look left
we're seeing exactly how your head's
moving so I want you to turn over your
right shoulder okay here we go you were
going to hear the plate hole in the
huddle and I want you to take your drop
I want you to actually play the
positions here you go just simulate your
footwork in your throw find the open guy
wrong okay so here we go ready ready
keep rise on the left once or just
crusty there you go that's better this
is a great way to train your mind
without affecting your body it's my turn
to come in there I can go execute
because as far as my brain is concerned
I've seen this before I practices before
and I know what to do let's go blitz
bigger okay so something like this with
the safety wide eyes are on the right
side we want to kill it in case they
bring something to the weak side
beginning of the week when we're
preparing for a certain opponent will
film their most popular blitzes their
top coverages bronze things that we need
to kind of look for and then throughout
the week we'll put the headset on and
kind of get through all our checks few
minutes every day it allows us to make
decisions faster more confidently and
play fast
Maryland had a specific blitz where
they'd bring the Sam and the safety off
the edge just by seeing it over and over
again it cut off the time that it takes
to process it and get to your run check
Kevin and the quarterbacks it didn't
start using it till the end of the year
because it wasn't ready once he started
using it and he thought okay this is
something think I would like to use and
his performance does that with this back
up on the ball he's telling me of
specific plays in the game where what he
saw in VR showed up in the game Hogan's
performance in the last three games of
the 2014 season saw his completion
percentage jumped from 64 to 76 and with
the trend continuing this season virtual
reality training is growing in
popularity this is one of those game
changers this is going from black and
white to color if you don't have it it's
not just taking a veg you're now at a
disadvantage a handful of NFL teams are
already using this including the dallas
cowboys and some of the college programs
David Shaw is good friends with davo
sweet he spent about 15 minutes before
our interview raving to me about the
difference this is already made for his
football team and Reese if people are
skeptical as to whether or not VR is
really the next big thing Mark
Zuckerberg recently purchased oculus the
company that makes those headsets from a
22 year old guy for two billion dollars
that's with a beery be why he all right
so she was a little off on her timeline
because it happened the year before but
that's okay so that was one of the
probably one of the you know we were on
60 minutes last year we were on ESPN
last year we were on CBS Sports we were
everywhere in the mainstream media that
was probably one of the coolest things
to have that you know watched by
millions of people on Saturday mornings
and more importantly millions of college
football coaches that are wondering why
don't i have this so so that's kind of
us in a nutshell and I the purpose of
today is not really to talk about what
we're doing as far as the coolness
factor it's more to talk about the
business and we're going to get there
we're going to give you guys I'm going
to give you guys a lot of details
hopefully answer a lot of your questions
but first i want to show you
is so I need a volunteer to come on up
and we'll get this fired up somebody who
presumably knows something about where
to look come on down right you put any
of you who have always wanted to go on
the practice field at Stanford now's
your chance this may be the only way you
get to do it put that on okay so we
won't do a ton here we'll just kind of
quickly give you an idea of what we're
doing okay there's a little blue dot
until the screen you see that move your
head up top videos I have the remote go
to training on the right go to blitz
pickup wash often sorry sorry go back
offense let's pick up number one okay so
what's your name c1 Mason all right so
I'm going to turn this down so Mason
right now is experiencing Stanford
football in 360 okay so the first thing
before Mason before we play this so I
want to note one thing Sam ponder and
the story got it wrong this is not a 3d
video game simulation this is real video
the reason why we went the real video
route two years ago when nobody else
knew what this was and there were a few
kind of goofy video games emulators out
there is because Jeremy in his lab at
Stanford has proven through research
that the human gait is so important for
a virtual simulation so if I'm a
quarterback and I'm trying to make a
decision of a receiver running a post a
defensive end going there a linebacker
going their safety going there if that
stuff doesn't time up and doesn't look
and feel real like it does in the real
world my brain is going to completely to
now so if we're trying to train a
quarterback or a linebacker or a safety
how to get you know mentally better on
the field it's got to look real so the
video game thing for us was not going to
happen it's real video so here you go
Mason here we go so this is a wrap
they sound the exact call that should be
there you got stuff behind you so don't
go too far okay so you can take a drop
and look around boom so this is a
simulation right this is a pre snap
blitz pickup Rep okay let me show you
this one this is for Christian McCaffrey
for blitz pickup you guys all know who
he is probably so notice how he looks
pretty tall to your right right so we
always want to simulate from the
viewpoint of the player so if Mason's
Christian get down in an athletic stance
hands on these okay now look to your
right now it looks a little more normal
right so this is a view or Christian a
blitz pickup view for Christian in the
running backs to learn what the
responsibility is against this
particular blitz Christian is going to
see himself Phil here and the point of
this is for him to do it you're careful
you got someone in front either the
point of this is for the running back to
do exactly what what Mason just did to
go in a room put on some headphones own
out and get down in their stance and
basically go through the mental and you
know the first couple steps of the
physical work of what they would do some
of you athletes in the room you know
when you get to this level and beyond
it's not physical anymore it's mental
right so how can we give you guys more
mental reps guys and girls how can we
give the athlete more mental reps to
actually you know actually have them
perform better on the field last one go
to seven on seven on the left go to
number two and will back you up to
number one look down over your right
shoulder look down on your right
shoulder there you go now you're in the
huddle listen to the play call fine so
this is the clip from ESPN let's see if
you can find the open receiver see if
you were paying attention turn back
around okay now to pick us up to your
life you got a podium right here okay
now keep your eyes forward when the ball
snapped and find the open guy sack god
you messed up just like Sam all right so
look we're going to run it again look
there Blitzer wide open what to the left
there you go okay so go and take it off
you my hand all right
alright so so as far as our product is
concerned one of the reasons why we were
so successful last year was the scenario
that just happened okay we could see
what he was seeing in the screen on in
the headset in real time so when he had
his eyes here I knew right away that he
was looking in the wrong spot right so
when he tilts his head back this way we
know that he got it right and this works
for linebackers this works for safety's
this works for you know obviously
quarterbacks baseball players whatever
we're doing the fact that we can mirror
the display now takes this from a
training tool where I'm going to go in
there to get reps in an infinite number
of times and build that you know myelin
sheath around my brain and get better
mentally and now it turns into a
coaching tool where Tina can sit here
and watch how I interact in the virtual
seen in the real world because I promise
you the player is going to look at the
field in here exactly like they would in
the real world hands down I know
somebody sitting in the middle of the
room he was the Stanford football player
once Owen that's probably right right
okay so so this this is what we're doing
this is what we're doing from eight from
a product standpoint now for the purpose
of this class and the purpose of
entrepreneurship and to teach you guys
some things about business I'm going to
give you the background so this is it
this is the only slide left in the whole
presentation and we're going to walk
through as much of this as we can so the
first thing that I want to do is talk
about how this thing's started okay
because I think it's really really
important I was sitting in your guys's
shoes let's see what am i'm 30 years old
so i graduated in 2007-2008 from sanford
aiko termed played football red shirt
was here for five years when i came back
as a graduate assistant i got my masters
in media studies and I got it wasn't
with an emphasis in virtual reality I
actually was in this class so I was
sitting at my desk during the football
season needed one unit to get me up to
the minimum number and at 10pm I would
watch these lectures in the night would
write in like you have to for the one
unit requirement I love it I never
missed a class by the way so but it was
I was virtually there so that that was
my that was my experience to how I got
back to San Fran I did do my MBA at USC
one of the things that I always like to
communicate to young people like
yourself is when I was your age so how
many freshmen in the room
okay sophomores juniors seniors ok so
those hands it wasn't until I was a
senior that I actually started thinking
about you know the real world and it
probably wasn't even till I was a
fifth-year senior so I was interviewing
for consulting jobs banking jobs etc I
didn't know what consulting was until I
was a fifth-year senior because I hadn't
even thought twice about it so one of
the things that I really really
encourage you guys everybody to do is to
you know this place is really really
special and when I was at USC all I
would do is brag about how special
Stanford was and I would always say I
didn't take advantage of it enough as an
undergrad so the position that you were
in you have to soak up this place for
everything that's worth you know people
like me coming back and talking to you
and being very candid this happens all
the time so take advantage of it because
you're probably sitting next to somebody
right now that has a really really cool
idea and you can do something post post
graduation that you're passionate about
because being a job you don't like is
absolutely miserable I think anyone
would attest that so I came back to
Stanford I came back to be a football
coach I did an MBA I was kind of
thinking know what I did business I
liked it I can see myself doing a lot of
things but if I don't see coaching by
the time I'm 30 I'm gonna regret it
forever so I came back I was on the path
to be a coach just like you saw in that
story my master's thesis was this and
coach Shaw SAT me down in December of
2014 and he said get out of here go
start a company you're about a year
ahead of everybody else you're not the
typical coach you just got your fourth
degree you're smart get out of here so
coach Shaw is our only investor to date
on he gave us about I can't tell you
exactly what he gave us but but by the
time we put his money together on me
putting in five thousand dollars of my
own money Jeremy putting in five
thousand dollars of his own money couple
others we raised $50,000 and the goal
was to just sell the one team last year
so on january second of 2015 we open for
business you know I met with lawyers try
to come up with a company name did all
the you know the bells and whistles of
the paperwork and the goal was can we
sell this to one team it was me
full-time some of you who have been
Stanford fans for a long time may
remember the name trent edwards he was a
quarterback here played for the Buffalo
Bills for several years he was one of my
best friends he jumped on to kind of
lend credibility to what we were doing
for
a quarterback player standpoint Jeremy
is part of our company more in a
visionary role because he's a tenured
professor here so we kind of just can
tap into his brain whenever we need to
and then we had a grad student that was
kind of helping us out part time
building software can helped us you know
get this thing off the ground so really
it was like two point seven people when
you add it up and then by the time we
you know we needed a little more help my
best friend from from childhood was at
Wharton at the time he worked for the
FBI for many years and he came on as our
COO living in Philadelphia so you know
really we're like three point four
people trying to actually get this thing
off the ground trying to sell to one
team in 2015 and to me the 50,000 was
enough to travel around the country and
not feel the panic of like oh my god
were burning through cash right on which
we were but it's okay because we were
working towards a goal so five of the
first six college teams I met with in
March signed up on the spot and two
weeks later the Dallas Cowboys signed up
so we went from not knowing you know
what the hell we were doing trying to
just sell the one team to over a half a
million dollars in revenue just like
that and since this is a public public
facing video I'm not going to go into
the Nitty Gritty of what each team pays
because teams might be able to watch
this by and large it's the same but I
will tell you that between April first
and September first we went from
figuring out how to service six teams
and not knowing what the heck we were
doing to having six NFL teams and ten
colleges by the time the season started
then in the fall we did a virtual hockey
goalie simulator for Madison Square
Garden when you actually get down in the
stance you're literally stopping pucks
against real New York Rangers hockey
players then we did a big project for
visa and the New England Patriots so now
we were starting to figure out different
revenue streams of how to actually you
know make money in addition to the
training when all is said and done we
did over three million dollars in
revenue last year in our first year with
no funding and I'm sure the professors
in the room can tell you that is about
8.0 one percent chance for companies
that pretty much have nothing and have
no you haven't raised a dime in their
first year as far as where we're sitting
today I'll get to that but every team
that we have is on the two-year contract
so we're in a pretty good place to
continue to grow this thing organically
and we'll kind of talk about that as we
go
so deeper dive one of the big things
that I want to talk about today was the
art of bootstrapping so one of the
common misconceptions among the entire
Stanford football team who's still
bitter at me for leaving and not
coaching anymore is that I'm rich we did
three million in revenue last year we
run went from four to twenty nine people
basically overnight from June to August
fifth or so when a college camp started
we had to figure out how to actually
service all these teams that I was just
out on the road signing up over and over
and over again so we grew really really
fast um you have to pay people I my
salary last year was forty thousand
dollars okay we'll just put that on the
table this is an entrepreneurship class
if you want to start something you have
to be prepared to sacrifice and we have
people right now at our company that
this is an equity play for them and they
are literally just making enough money
to pay the bills these are people that
have Harvard MBAs Stanford MBAs people
that walked away from $250,000 jobs just
so they could be involved in something
that they are really really passionate
about and that they believe in so that
that's something that I really really
really want to emphasize one of the
tendencies in Silicon Valley is the
first question you ask somebody is how
much money of you raised and let you
know I all read inked magazine and
Forbes and fortune and all these things
when I'm flying all the time and it
would just read something recently about
like the 13 of the 30 under 30 all no
company that was mentioned did they talk
about revenue all it was was how much
they've raised well that doesn't mean
anything that doesn't mean look that
doesn't mean you're rich doesn't mean
you have a business that can succeed
raising money is great don't get me
wrong congratulations if you do it means
a lot especially if you do it from a
really reputable brand but the bottom
line is is that it's about bringing in
dollars as a business and I think today
with you know the the snapchats and the
instagrams and you know even uber to a
certain extent they're obviously
bringing a ton of cash they burn more
than they bring in you know basically
everyone at this school that's young and
then people that want to go out and get
rich they forget that businesses aren't
all about users right there at about
actually dollar in dollar out so one of
the things that we've done really well
so far is we bootstrapped our office for
the last nine months
has been a townhouse in menlo park it is
literally the size of this okay the
living room at any given on any given
day has 12 people crammed into it
there's three sitting on the stairs it
is not sexy it as a matter of fact when
people come meet with us I apologize in
advance and when they get there they
usually say no no we love this this
shows us that your humble this shows us
that you're hungry it's something that
actually we turn into a positive so one
of the things that you know that I've
been kind of hammering are our people
about from day one is guys if we don't
raise money if we can do this
organically we're in control right we
make our own decisions nobody's looking
over our shoulders as far as financial
flexibility that really goes a long way
if we want to pay someone a bonus at the
end of year for doing a good job we
don't have to worry about somebody
harping on us over our shoulder I'm not
saying that that can't happen if you do
raise money but thus far we've had a lot
of financial flexibility and it's been
really really neat and we're kind of a
cool success story in that regard now
that said you need money to run a
company so leaving us to number two
things cost money travel legal hardware
rent paying people etc everybody told me
from the very beginning all the way back
to when I was in business school and
entrepreneurship classes people always
say it's going to take twice as long and
it's going to cost twice as much as you
think it will and that could not be more
true we have been in a very fortunate
position to do things a lot faster than
I think then I think most people would
as far as moving really really really
really quickly but by and large if we
think a travel budget for something is
going to come out to you know five grand
over the course of a month it costs 10
or more so as you guys are thinking
about how to start start a business
trust me you have to plan for these
things moving to number three people
cost money one of the biggest things
that's been an eye-opener to me is that
I am now responsible for 29 paychecks
you know 28-29 if you count myself I
have a six month old I have a wife who
she works full time so that this is real
I mean this is not like pie in the sky
let's go start a company and let's get
rich I mean day in and day out it costs
money you need to pay the bills in every
single day I deal with people thinking
they should be paid more people
wondering what their future is I mean
it's all human resources things
that come up all the time and when
you're a startup and you're trying to do
it organically in bootstrap it it's
tough I mean luckily we haven't missed a
pay period yet but but trust me that's
real and when you're owed a
hundred-thousand-dollar check from an
NFL organization or a big brand or
something that you know is coming but it
may not be coming until next week and
payday is three days before that it
makes you sweat a little bit so could
these things we solved with raising
money yeah they could but for us we have
made the conscious decision as an
organization that we don't want to
dilute ourselves equity wise we like
that the like the position that we're in
so we're choosing to continue to go this
organic route but this is very very real
and one of the things that kind of stuck
out at me when we started this company
last year I was meeting with an NFL team
and I was talking to their video
coordinator and we had we were teaching
him how to do what we do on the field
and we had to train a member of his
staff and I said man I'm really
surprised like NFL you guys make all
this money you only have three video
guys on the staff some of the colleges
we meet with have like 19 because all
the students want to volunteer right and
get paid ten bucks an hour he's like
you'd be surprised how often a
ten-dollar our an employee a ten dollar
an hour employee doesn't show up for
work on the second week and I'm like
really this is the so-and-so insert team
name here this is one of the best brands
in the world he goes doesn't matter you
get what you pay for so this is a a team
where people would literally give their
left arm to work for them and put that
that logo on their chest and they still
have people that don't show up when they
only pay them an hourly rate so right
now for us like I said we've got some
really really smart people some really
experienced people we live in the Bay
Area you can't afford to pay those
people $50,000 so that's something that
you really have to think about going
forward when you're trying to start a
company as you guys grow you need cash
and you need to be able to compensate
people appropriately relative what
they're doing the next thing operations
are absolutely critical okay I cannot
emphasize this enough if when you guys
go to business school guys and girls
some of you that may go to business
school one day and you fall asleep in an
Operations class because you think it's
boring trust me you're doing yourself a
disservice okay and this doesn't
necessarily mean factory line operations
right widgets and a fit in Toyota you
know lean six and efficiency and all
that that's not what I'm talking about
that's really really high level stuff
at my level at strivers level it's you
know ordering computer prepping it
making sure it doesn't have you know now
we're on it when you send it out to you
know the Dallas Cowboys just little
things that add up making sure you send
the remote and the remote part that are
on this machine right now because if you
forget something they're going to call
you and say what the heck's going on and
they're going to wonder why they're
paying so much money for your service so
all of the little things with operations
are absolutely critical on the other
thing I'll add to that is it really
really helps to have everybody in the
same room at the same time it's very
very tempting in today's day and age to
think oh I can do this remotely we can
have someone in New York we can have
someone in Wisconsin we kind of someone
in San Diego we can skype we can you put
our VR headset on and talk to each other
virtually trust me decisions are best
made and people are the most efficient
when you are in the same room together
and one of the major issues that we're
having right now is we are 29 people and
only 15 of them live in the Bay Area and
14 of those are probably six of those 14
that don't live in the Bay Area are some
of our best people people that I wish
could be sitting next to me every day
not because I want to babysit anybody
because when we're in the same room and
we talked out ideas you know you're
missing someone on the phone you're
trying to play tag guys or guys and
girls are traveling all the time it's
really really tough so to me operations
is not only figuring out how to
efficiently operate your business but
also figure out how to just efficiently
make decisions and part of that is being
together in the same room that's very
very important the next point passion is
contagious so the number one thing
people always tell me after I speak and
I've done a lot in the last year as they
come up and say man you're if you're
really passionate about this clearly you
know thank you it's great to hear I it's
just natural for me but when you're
going to pitch whether you're trying to
raise money whether you're trying to
sell something whether you're trying to
convince your you know someone to come
on board the company I mean I'm going to
be honest I convince someone that was
making $300,000 to come make 60 that
that's a big deal and the passion goes a
long way so if you're not passionate
about what you're doing you're not doing
what you should be doing you're the long
line of work move on to the next thing
because this is very very real and if
you're a founder if you're a co-founder
if you're you know if you're the fourth
person in and you're starting to grow
though
organization from the top down on the
bottom up on you have to have passion
because if you don't show up every day
with a smile on your face I mean let's
be honest athletes in the room how many
do we have okay training gets pretty
monotonous doesn't doesn't it at times
game day and this is your as you're
speaking my language that's why I'm
calling out the athletes but you know
computer scientists writing code isn't
always fun but seeing the end result is
really really cool that's what business
is so some of you know me me being gone
six days there are six straight weeks
last year when my wife was pregnant with
a baby on the way a month out that
wasn't fun but selling six teams over
that court that time period was awesome
so if you don't have passion for what
you're doing then you have to move on ok
friends and family so of the 29 people
that work for us I have known half of
them since college one is my brother one
is my best friend from childhood who
have known since I was five years old
and one is one of my professors who's
more of a visionary former professor but
he's still involved so half the people
that work for us I'm very very close
with that is really really risky
everybody always says don't go to the
business with friends or family because
it could blow up in your face one of the
reasons why I made that decision a we
had to move fast so last year we
literally went from six to twenty
professional and college teams in the
period of about 30 days so we had to
staff up really quickly additionally we
started getting so much media and so
much attention that we had to strike
while the iron is hot so one and we got
kept getting calls every day emails
calls i mean the dallas cowboys coach he
literally called me out of the blue
found my phone number said Derek I'd
love you to come to Valley Ranch and
show this thing to me because I've been
dreaming about it for 20 years so to
have to have that much traction and to
want to take advantage of it it had to
be more than just me so we had to move
quickly one of the advantages that you
guys have right now is your best friends
in life today your peers are going to be
Stanford graduates okay so the decision
that I made was I could go look for
people that I don't know I could go look
for people that are probably maybe just
as qualified but I don't know him I
don't trust them like let's just be
honest I'd rather to bring six stamp
people on board yeah I'm not saying that
it's Stanford's the be all end all and
that if you want somewhere else you're
not qualified but you know I kind of
looked at our situation I said okay some
of my best friends are really smart
athletically accomplished business-wise
accomplished I trust them they went to
Stanford you know I know that pedigree
so what I mean they're my friend that's
the only reason why I wouldn't hire them
and to date it's actually gone pretty
well I'm one of the things that I tell
people I probably tell our company
that's like six every six weeks you know
as long as you're doing your job there
won't be any issues here so the only
time friends and family relationships
become a problem is when one side has
expectations that the other side doesn't
meet or when expectations are different
so my brother is working for me right
now I trust him one hundred percent that
I'm always going to get everything that
he has if those expectations don't match
up that that's when we have problems so
I'm not saying that this is the
necessary you know this is esther the
right way to go i may lose three
friendships over this and then the day
who knows but it was something that we
had to do for our business to make sure
that it could succeed another thing that
I'll tell you guys too is you know it's
very common to go into business with
friends or family because you talk about
ideas you have to be honest from the
beginning one of my friends that I
brought on board we have Type A
personalities both of us practically you
know cut each other off when we said why
we wouldn't work together like we're
worried that we're going to butt heads
so as long as you can address that
upfront and be very very straightforward
with people it really really goes a long
way you know we haven't had any issues
yet I don't think we ever will the next
thing people need direction so one of
the things that I've learned very
quickly is of the 29 people working for
us 1.75 people can actually work without
being told what to do and I'm not
insulting anybody in our company by any
means I've told the whole group that I'm
and I'm the one okay so the other people
make up point 75 so so one of the things
that that that's that's really
interesting is this is a school this is
a culture of self starters okay but
trust me when you're running an
organization whether it's ten or ten
thousand if you don't tell people what
your expectations are and you don't keep
people on the loop on what you want them
to do they'll be sitting there doing
this because
lot of times even if someone's really
really good really really motivated
really really smart like they're still
going to wonder what you're thinking
they're going to wonder what the vision
is for what we're supposed to be doing
day in and day out so giving people
direction and clearly communicating
often goes a long way one thing that
I've done that I feel has been very
effective because I get an email from
you know five people every time I do it
is like once every six weeks I try to
write like a state of Stryver email to
the group and its way longer than people
want to read I usually do it on a plane
flight takes me two hours I don't have
much else to do when I'm on the plane in
that situation but I literally go
through everything football sales
baseball sales college football sales
you know interactives financing money
status HR operations I just write
paragraphs for each thing to keep
everybody in the loop and most of the
time I get an email back right away from
someone that's up at like 1130 at night
and they say thanks for sending that I
really appreciate that you're so honest
and transparent with what's going on
because I live in Virginia and I don't
get to see you guys every day so this
really makes me feel like them in the
loop so giving people Direction keeping
people informed really really goes a
long way the last couple here so be
willing to sprint when in sales mode so
like I said last year I spent june
twenty third to sep tember 5th out of
the house they came home for one day to
do that ESPN story our baby was due
September 22nd so you can do the math on
how while pregnant my wife was she was
not happy with that she said if you
don't make it by the time the baby's
born you don't have a choice in what we
named him and among other things so but
but here's the in that that was kind of
the theme of last year I traveled a lot
and I still do unfortunately but if
you're not willing to sprint we have a
guy working right now for us he's 48
years old he's the oldest person or
accompanied by a landslide I think he's
the only person over 35 with the
exception of Jeremy we don't
discriminate by age trust me it just
kind of has worked out that way but he's
been through the dot-com boom com bust
he's been in startups he's done really
well for himself as far as his fit
within those organization and he's
basically told us guys you know I'm just
going to tell you something from my
experience work-life balance right now
does not exist okay we have to be
willing to do whatever it takes to bring
in customers right now and to get this
thing
off the ground get it going the right
way because right now vr is a rising
tide industry and Stryver is one of the
best position companies out of anybody
on the whole planet we have a real use
case for VR we were the only I think we
were one of the only profitable
companies last year in this space only
one that maybe even charged for a
product to be honest so we're in a
really really good spot and if you're
not willing to sprint no we wouldn't
have 20 teams right now if it wasn't for
me being gone for the for those six
weeks last year it sucked at the time
being away from home was not fun I used
to hate FaceTime now I love it but um
but it's very very necessary and then
the last thing here people people people
so every time I I've given a talk like
this I always give my wife a shout out
she's an absolute Saint and most of the
young people in the room can't
appreciate marriage right now some of
the older people can but if you don't
have that foundation whether it's a
friend a group of friends a girlfriend a
boyfriend a wife a husband then then the
success just isn't as fun and one of the
really cool things for me so far is we
pulled the trigger really fast and some
people last year we have not hired any
rotten eggs so far and out of 29 people
that's tough because odds are that
usually you're going to with a couple
times and we've gotten you know thank
the Lord we've gotten really really
lucky because people is what it's all
about and I've met with you know a lot
of big companies that I know are looking
at us for acquisition one day whether
it's in a week or two years and they've
all told me you buy people ideas are a
dime a dozen execution is what's all
about in people execute so the last two
things what's next for Stryver and
what's next for virtual reality so I
already talked about you know kind of my
opinion on the VR space right now and
I'm not gonna I'm not certainly not
downplaying or you know insulting
anybody that's in a business that's
unlike Stryver because I think there's
going to be some really cool stuff that
comes out this industry in my opinion is
going to be an all-out arms race for the
next three to five years and then we're
going to kind of see whether or not
people actually grab on to this some of
you may remember Google glass that was
supposed to be the next big thing never
really went anywhere 3d TV never really
went anywhere so why do we think bulkier
headsets on faces are actually going
be more successful I don't know so I
think you're going to see a lot of
really cool stuff come out in the next 6
9 12 24 months and then we're going to
see how sticky this stuff actually is I
mentioned before training doctors curing
phobias you know maybe that courtside
seat at the game and the heads that does
actually look pretty good in 16 months I
think you're going to see some neat use
cases we'll see how ready people are to
actually grab onto this stuff because if
it doesn't happen now you I don't think
it's ever going to happen 10-15 years
ago 20 years ago vr was supposed to
explode it never went anywhere so now is
the time so what's next what's next for
a striver one of the things that Tina
really wanted me to talk about was what
are we pursuing but more importantly
what aren't we pursuing so our game plan
as of now is to absolutely own sports
sports is a huge market we're doing
training stuff we're doing fan
experience stuff we're doing little
projects we're doing bigger projects if
we own sports we feel like that's going
to take us to take us to where we want
to go because one of the really really
cool things that's happened in the last
year is we're one of the only be our
companies that's actually in the
mainstream press so when somebody you
know reads an article that we're working
with the San Francisco 49ers to train
their athletes they say hmm maybe that
would help train our employees using
virtual reality boom let's call Stryver
so we're getting all of these emails and
calls because we're in the news and
quite frankly nobody else really is as
far as the mainstream press so for us
we're going to own sports and then we're
going to see where that takes us in all
of these other spaces we did a project
for ABC and the Oscars a month ago where
we did like a behind the scenes in 360
and we turn it around in like 18 hours
and then they showed it to everybody on
facebook and youtube and people that
owned headsets which there aren't many
of them now but ABC chose us to do that
knowing that we had never done anything
like that before because they trusted
the work that we've done you know with
professional sports organizations so you
know we r sports company first art at
but our tagline is immersive performance
training not immersive athletic training
not even immersive sports training
immersive performance training because
when we decide to go down the path of
training team has to be a better sales
person when she works for Cisco for
example that's performance that's not
sports but its performance is helping
her perform better than her job so we've
kind of set ourselves up to
go down the path to know potentially do
a lot of other different things so that
takes us to we got about what 10 minutes
left for questions that is my email
address if anybody in this room has
anything more they like to ask follow-up
get lunch if you want to work for us
we're looking for engineers who will
take next to no money to come over
please please IAM it please email me and
with that we've got 12 minutes so i will
answer anything that anybody wants feel
free yeah how do you gotta hate your
time with your time spent on average so
I would say email is your best friend
and your worst enemy I prob like right
now like today I spoke an Intel this
morning I'm here that's like six hours
or I'm away from my email and i'll
probably have you know 54 unread emails
that i have to go through tonight and
unfortunately these aren't things that
I'm just like cc'd on this is like Derek
what about this hey Stryver we'd like
you to do this and you have to respond
fast so I probably spend half my day on
email unfortunately writing proposals is
something that's that's really big I
have a master's in journalism I'm really
really sensitive to bad writing so all
the proposals go through me which that
is not a good sustainable strategy long
term but when you have you know that
that's something that we're going to do
for now until other people show that
they can make it perfect every single
time and then right now I'm are I'm our
head of sales to last year of the 23
teams that we worked with I sold the 22
of them so and that is not sustainable
long-term but the fact that matter is is
I'm the best salesperson of the company
so you know over the next three weeks
I'm going to be in a different city
every day meeting with teams and just
you know trying to get trying to get
more change in the door yeah um can you
tell a little bit about your approach
towards I feel like american football
happens to be a combination of where
there's like a lot of static time great
question if versus like fluid or
something massive sure so one of the one
of the reasons why BR works for football
is because i start in a static spot i
read i react and I go right so it's
perfect for football now there are some
positions where they move free snap and
you know it is what it is on those plays
I'm a quarterback you know I'm kind of
in one spot nine out of ten times so
it's perfect another reason why football
so good is because it's really
physically demanding so can I get that
virtual rep and not get injured or
injure myself more if I'm rehabbing or
something so for football it's perfect
baseball you know I'm in one spot I'm
trying to recognize a pitch right now
the clarity just isn't there it has a
little little ways to go but it that's
the next best use case may be better
than football when it's ready to go
beyond that soccer the fields huge you
move around too much hockey my grandpa
played in the NHL but I never really
appreciated how fast hockey moved till
we got on the ice for the first time and
tried to shoot something from a static
decision-making standpoint it never
happens maybe the goalie so these at
basketball we have an NBA team but you
know they're kind of an experimental
mobile they try to figure it out so one
of the biggest challenges and those
sports and even football where it's
tailor-made is convincing coaches to
change so like right now you saw the
clip you guys all saw how we do it at
Stanford I mean I hate when that this is
on the national media because it just
shows the competition what we do but
when you put the camera like right there
on the field I mean you have to convince
a coach that's been doing it for 35
years hey let's change let's bring this
new apparatus on to the field let's
change your practice schedule a little
bit that's not easy I mean that's a
Herculean task so not only are the
movement sports really challenging from
a visual standpoint but from a
conceptual standpoint getting them to
buy in is really really tough oh you
spoke about like soaking in everything
at Stanford especially for the
undergrads here as I'm sure what sorts
of things you did when you were here may
be at your MBA that are paying off now
that your buddy right so I played too
many video games here his undergrad
played too much golf online poker was
legal back then that was really stupid
but uh and I played football so I put a
lot of time into that too honestly I
kind of figured it out pretty late in
the game so when I did my masters in
journalism i took an entrepreneurship
class it was called what was it called
digital journalism I forget but anyway
it it was the first time I even even
heard what entrepreneur was and that
kind of turned me on to there were some
MBA students in the class so I was just
starting to pick their brain you know
have lunch with them ask questions hey
would you do in your work life and then
my own back to business school the
biggest thing that I did honestly was
pay attention in class I mean I know
that sounds kind of lame and the
teachers were probably you know I'm
happy that I'm saying that
but like doing the reading there's a
reason that you're doing reading and one
of the things that I noticed when I was
in the work world was when you can sit
around a room of eight people and you
can talk about that random study that
you read that applies to why this sales
tactic might work they all look at you
like wow where'd you come up with that
and like you know I probably got to see
on that test when I was supposed to
supposed to know that right but it comes
up later and you look like the smartest
person in the room so aside from
actually kind of taking school or more
seriously in my graduate life just just
being out there like right now you guys
are all required to be here because it's
your class I'm sure there's 10 more of
these that will happen in the next week
where you know when I was an undergrad
Bill Gates came and spoke just you know
reading about what these people think
going to talks like this and coming up
with you know taking that one little
thing away that you want it really goes
a long way so yeah so Derek what
motivates you there lots of people is
taking technology yards football do
honey sure what drives you every single
day so well first and foremost we live
in an 800 square foot apartment that has
no air conditioning so we need to make
enough money to get out of there that's
uh that's number one the family first so
I like when I was in when I was in
before business school and I was working
in consulting and quite miserable I had
no passion for what I was doing and I
always thought I wanted to start my own
thing and I'm doing it right so when so
the biggest thing has been not losing
right and actually making this
successful whether I make a hundred
thousand dollars or a hundred million
dollars off this thing I don't care
we've got people in our company that has
told me it's not about money it's about
winning and that's I mean that's awesome
to have the motivation to not fail to me
goes a really long way and you know for
me personally when coach Shaw SAT me
down and basically told me you need to
do this I mean I even said low can i
still stay on the staff like what if
something goes wrong he's like well yeah
you can but i would put everything I
have into that so I talked to my wife
talked to my parents and it was kind of
like have already I've always wanted to
do my own thing sports are involved I'm
passionate about sports and this is
tailor-made right i mean this is this is
ready to roll why
that that I mean that was kind of a
thing that kicked the whole thing off
and then now that we're so deep in it
truthfully it's the 29 people that work
for us and I don't want to let them down
and you know if we we've we've talked a
lot in our company about should we move
so-and-so here should we move so-and-so
here operationally this person isn't
really getting it done you know people
have gotten pissed at me like that
person's got to go there screwing up too
much I don't want to fire anybody enough
that person needs a paycheck they're a
human being so that that's been the
biggest motivator so far is to not not
fail for myself and everybody that's
working for us yeah could you do tennis
could I could be new tennis we're
working on something yeah just wondering
if there's a woman's floor if you could
Google thin women in this way sure yeah
problem is a lot of kind of programs and
just don't have a lot of money and the
stuffs really expensive right now so as
that as the cost comes down then
something we're looking at whitworth the
Limu volleyball stuff yeah let's talk
afterwards it was yeah um which skills
not on the heel that have been the most
valuable to you so good question to fold
when I was an undergrad it took me three
years of being a backup a backup kicker
which is the loneliest job in all of
sports in the most boring position in
the history of sports took him three
years to finally see the field so that
you know that as far as persistence what
motivates you kind of seem that carrot
out there I mean I waited a long time
and Tina didn't mention this but when we
when we upset us see when we were 42
point underdogs in 2007 that kind of a
game that kind of kicked off Stanford
football I kicked the game-winning extra
point in that game so that was like a
really really gratifying culmination to
my five years at Stanford I also went 0
for 4 in a game five five weeks later
and we lost but we know we're
remembering the positive so so so for
one persistence right and I think one of
the things that I did a really really
good job of when I was not playing was
looking at the guy above me that I was
his back up and saying looking at
everything that he did that I didn't
want to do the way he acted on the field
the way he you know worked hard or
didn't work hard kind of just learning
from observation vs
in from experience and then when I
coached which isn't playing but you know
aren't being on the field coaching same
thing uh truthfully the biggest thing
that frustrated me about coaching was
why are we here until midnight when we
you know we literally could be here
until 8pm so just the lack of
operational efficiency and this isn't
just coaching this happens everywhere
but in coaching like if you're not there
to one in the morning you're doing
something wrong that's the culture and
to me that is just so backward it's
about productivity not not activity so
one of the things that I've no really
tried to instill despite the fact that
I'm working you know 18-hour days all
the time because there's so much to do
is you know I'm telling all of our
people like get it done and do your
thing and you know we're gonna have to
grind at times and put work first over a
lot of things but you know it's all
about efficiency I don't care if you
leave at three thirty in the afternoon
as long as you have done what you needed
to get done roles are like playing in
your company and in your personal life
at this point uh so I've tried I don't
have a personal assistant I've been told
that I should get one just to take all
the travel and email off my plate I'm
trying to hire her to do that but she's
pretty good at her own job so she
doesn't want to do that truthfully just
just support she's not involved in our
company at all as a matter of fact we've
had a couple wives at our company that
have wanted to start like a striver
wives group and she just does not get
into that stuff she doesn't want oh I'm
the CEOs wife she doesn't want to do
that so mainly it's just it's just
support it's her not it she has never
once said to me like do you really have
to go on that trip because she just gets
it she knows that this is part part of
the deal right now no or so she works
full-time yeah what'd she do she works
at a tech startup called medallia in
Palo Alto she's the executive assistant
to the CTO there one more yep one more
yeah you do you know any product idea
problem related to social aspect like
maybe phobia or social interaction could
be educational well yeah so that's
that's a but what an area that people
really think we're VR could work so in
education right I'm sitting I'm sitting
in London and now I can be in a
classroom in Palo Alto right somebody
could there could be a camera right here
and there could be 10 million people
looking through
heads as if they're right here one of
the other things we're doing is we're
trying to teach about geography to a
bunch of you know sixth graders they're
kind of tuning out they don't care here
throw on this headset and be right at
the base of an Egyptian pyramid that's
something that could take off I am not
very big on social VR like where I have
a headset on Tina has a headset on i'm
looking at an avatar of her like I just
like the real world so that's just not
my thing but someone's gonna make a lot
of money off that because it you know
with your guys's generation you're gonna
you're going to grab onto that stuff for
sure so what is that do you know there's
a few out there yeah I don't know the
names but there's a few out there I'm
sure you'll agree this was totally
inspiring please join me and thank you